o
k
is kirby time
the online setting has been changed to
use your gameplay information is now
visible to other players all over the
world that's terrifying
as you progress through the game check
in with wise waddle dee to access global
gameplay information and see how you
stack up i just
i keep
i accidentally muted myself
i keep wanting to
um
say things that would be sucking
innuendos and thus
i'm glad i'm stopping myself okay kirby
is a game that's a bit wilder and more
challenging you're telling me this is a
difficult kirby game
no let's go
give me dark souls kirby i'm ready
i love kirby so much
look at him
look
my boy
my son
oh i have a statue of that it lights up
kirby on the little star oh it's slow-mo
oh my god my heart
[Music]
oh my god i should turn it down
there we go that seems like a good
balance let me know if it's not
kirby no a storm
you
hate those
possibly indeed
i need to make the webcam smaller
oh my gosh
[Music]
probably about that about that it should
be all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow
also yeah in case i put this first hour
up on
uh
youtube for reference this is a twitch
stream
um if i end up publishing it just
because then you'll see me interact with
chat which i don't usually do in my
first hour game please
hello buddy are you okay
i'm a tiny pink friend
look at my sweet boy look at him
my gosh
okay
oh we right into it huh
[Music]
oh
man
this is a whole new aspect ratio of the
big boy cub right here
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i guess just kirby games make me so
happy
he is my mane in smash
yeah
yeah you got him
the big suck
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
let's go it's it's very um it is very
last of us see
the vibes
i like that he he splits the air out
the fact that it's a rainbow
oh my god
what's going on up here
[Applause]
oh what did i just grab
[Applause]
yeah got it
boom
we gaming out here
oh hey cutie what's up is that a real
live pokemon you didn't see anything
don't worry about it
it actually does look like one of my
foster dogs
get
i just threw that thing into the [ __ ]
abyss
oh man
if i'm gonna do this the whole game this
is gonna get physically painful to play
because i'm just gonna smile the whole
time
we saw this in the gameplay trailers and
stuff
[Music]
yeah so i'm a big kirby fan
i think some of the curbs are bad
they're not all good games some of them
aren't good games
this one from the jump i have thought
looked like an absolute banger
[Music]
not on my watch
[Applause]
that wasn't link
yeah look at us go
do you have a down b
[Music]
this is the best day of my life game of
the year move over elden ring
[Music]
what even is god of war ragnarok now
it's actually been kind of hurtful
seeing everybody be like congrats eldon
ring like friends that i have saying
that okay
go to war ragnarok schedule 2022 but
that's fine
get
[Music]
well kobe that was just littering
also this music is like kind of
disproportionately hyped oh you want me
to hover why
oh just tutorializing
the down b is not quite a down b this is
not breakable is what i'm gathering from
that okay
let's go
[Music]
what is that
i um
had seen people say that it has last of
us two vibes
and it totally does
my favorite
post-apocalyptic game is actually kirby
and i've forgotten whatever this game is
loving this aspect ratio change look at
you look at you go look how look how
smooth that was
[Music]
eating the absolute [ __ ] out of people
curb
yes sir that's like chun li
[Music]
he's a god
[Laughter]
oh man have a great day
[Music]
okay
and the fact that there are sound
effects for every footstep oh
you know you know what i'm saying
carrot
oh carrot give more sword of course
everyone knows carrot give more sword
all right let's go let's go let's go
kirby has studied the blade you're
absolutely right thank you maddie
mording
hbo adaptation whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
was this cobby is carby
it's already happening
oh no not
pokemon
they really do look like the two foster
dogs i've had combined
queen athena's we call them
[Music]
sometimes
kirby suck too hard
you know
sometimes
kirby
do not know when to stop suck
[Music]
like feeling that i have of this mixture
of nostalgia and entertainment and just
thinking something so cute that it's
comical is how i feel when watching most
nintendo directs and it blows my mind
the amount that people harass me for
being a sony shell or for being an xbox
shell that nobody has ever done it with
nintendo
not one time
every nintendo direct i'm there like oh
i love you so much oh my god
never
twitter threads about how i'm a sony
show and how i'm an xbox show
videos live streams podcasts never for
nintendo despite this
clear
love for nintendo
i'm just so like giddy about it nobody
ever calls it out maybe because they
don't care it doesn't it isn't
considered part of the war
the corporate war that we must all fight
look who you go
he still got the hat on
[Music]
it's the cutest thing i've ever seen
i'm actually crying a little bit oh my
god
oh okay
okay what's that which one's turbo is it
b it is look at me go
[Music]
yeah you you break through that building
because you accidentally inhaled a car
you [ __ ] heathen
[Music]
an actual criminal
oh you're right his little feet on the
back
oh
doing doughnuts in the grass that's sick
boom
get out of my face also the gameplay
variety just from the jump
incredible
yet no the bridge is not enough for me
i don't care about rock formations i'm
cobby
uh i guess the good news is wait i need
to see i need to see it from the back
cubby can you let me see it from the
back
i missed the jump
good noises oh my god
[Music]
how oh
get out of here
oh there's so much cash up here who left
all this here okay
cobby does have a cussy
as i believe they call it
confirmed
because i'm pretty sure that's an
exhaust pipe
clobby has two two [ __ ]
do with that information what you will
please do nothing with that information
i would actually really prefer that
people keep sexualizing my boy i would
never
this is nice beach
it's also the music is so christmassy
it feels at odds with
the game in a way that i love boombox
what is happening
[Music]
oh my god
we don't deserve it
we don't deserve any of this what have
we done to deserve this
[Music]
this is a full anime
theme song
[Music]
featuring
queen
athena yeah running wild
totally
oh my god they've made this so romantic
cubby you just swallowed a car
that's all you've done
you just you stall are we racing
seagulls now why did you get frowny
oh my god
the dog lay egg i guess i guess that
makes sense for cubby
wow
that's messed up
i always suspected that birds were evil
like as a conglomerate
oh it seems like it's no more cobby time
unless we just we just jump
i will not spit kirby would never
i don't want to get out of the car
damn it okay oh i i don't want the car
to get out of me
i think is what i meant to say that
technically
all right fine
the animation okay no i have to get out
kirby we have to get out of the car to
cut cars to get out of here we'll meet
again my friend
that time i'm just trying to hit it with
the sword
i can't it's not possible devastatingly
i have so many problems whenever i come
back to playing the switch
with pressing the wrong buttons it will
never not be a problem for me i keep
hitting x instead of y
[Music]
he does little little air bubs
just what you know
how did we get this blessed
that's what i'm asking
dude
why what are you doing with them
[Music]
you can't make me turn on the dogs
though you can't make me turn on the
dogs they look so much like queen bee
uh it's nuts okay i'm gonna make my
webcam
a bit smaller
go down here while this wrap this is
occurring
digital ocean over here
wow
beautiful okay that looks like a jinjo
okay okay
it's so chunny it's incredible no you
don't
i am such a [ __ ] chad
you do not stand a chance there is just
no way
have you seen me
y'all get out of my face i got a frowny
face
[Music]
i chose the hard mode i assume it gets
hard somewhere
hello tiny mouse
[Music]
this is the best thing that's ever
happened to me
it goes so hard like it's not just like
maybe a cute little elevation like when
mario jumps at a star that was a whole
[ __ ] choreographed dance
oh my god
uh thank you zacky boy
for the two months thank you my friend
appreciate you
okay but what about those other guys the
waddle dees they were all captured and
hang on no she wouldn't sound like that
but what about those those other guys
the waddle dees yeah she'd probably
sound something like that i feel pretty
good about that
we fought those beasts as hard as we
could but they kept coming back for more
now i'm the only one left i have to go
save them i have to
okay cutie let's go
i have us
well we could go back for the car though
it sure is my name is kirby
i'm elf olin
[Music]
kirby chad moves does he always frown
when sorting or is it just one oh he
does oh my god
thank you toilet noggin and ned pets
thank you my friends
hey kirby
[Music]
oh my god
wow i actually didn't know this had
co-op
or i knew and i forgot it happens a lot
planet pop star
[Music]
that's sick
[Music]
where are we dropping boys
till
tilted tap tilted towers
[Music]
downtown grassland
all right let's roll
[Music]
clear the stage save the hidden waddle
dee's question mark question mark
question mark profit
[Music]
that's such an old meme
[Music]
they just did a very bad job
wow look at the frame rate um the one
that's further away
uh did a really bad job of making me
just like the critters look at the look
at the one that's the furthest away
on the ledge just checkerboard
[Music]
boom again
absolute chad kirby
i will
just destroy you i will ruin your life
you will never be the same again you
don't even stand a chance it looks like
he's just swashing them away he's just
that's it
no not happening
[Music]
make five tulips blue
that did not go according to plan
that was maybe less chatty of kirby but
that's fine i could use more sword
oh you were literally in tall grass
they're not even pretending they're not
pokemon oh look at the sleepy one
no
it's too cute
boom
get out of my face rabbit
hey that was that was
that was a real tricky
i'd recognize that the game would want
me to
i know that it would
i'm not gonna do it i will take the l on
the level of completion
it's not happening
i don't want to do it
thank you odd eyes
[Music]
cake
[Music]
hang on let me beat up this fly first
secret secrets
yeah by the secret way
is there a car down here because if not
i don't want it
blimp
and then what are these i don't know
what kind of plant that even is not sure
get out of my face
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
do i have unlimited soda no i don't okay
noted a bit more careful with the soda
oh you could just pick more up
bro
chill
carrots
hang on hang on let me scoop this out
first
kirby not want to spit
[Music]
i do have to i have to spit
i mean kirby does
[Music]
it's unfortunate
male privilege is being able to play
this game
nothing to worry about all the clips
all right
[Music]
i wonder how they make the kirby noises
like
what is
that should i go up or should i go on
no i know i'm going up
we can deal with that bull in a second
so triumphant man
thank you i beat nick
[Music]
all right let's go let's get him
i wish i was a car
[Music]
but i'm not and that's okay
[Music]
dude
kirby over here absolute chad you think
you stood a chance
no
none of you did
i will ruin your [ __ ] day the second
you look in my direction
don't even think about it
hi
i was just making a joke zerala i was
just making a joke
[Music]
how are you gonna have a smile on your
face like that while throwing actual
bumps
you're a [ __ ] menace
jeez
get out of here white boy what are you
gonna go storm the capital i don't think
so i don't think so
[Music]
this is too many bumps
uh
i'm fine okay it's fine
things are maybe more
i'm so excited okay
[Applause]
i can't believe they're just giving us
bang his back tobacco right from the
start
dude
[Music]
why would i need multiple mouthfuls
[Music]
it just doesn't end
[Music]
do you think they knew what they were
doing
[Music]
oh my god look at his little waddle
oh my god i don't know why people aren't
talking about this like it is a game of
the year contender when it clearly is
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
get out of here cute dogs
hey who you calling common mouth
lance whoa
oh we got slapped about there we got
slapped about that cub
didn't feel good about that one
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna stand for
that we're gonna go [ __ ] him up
you're a chad you wouldn't let a bull
get away
oh not again
[Music]
oh i just can't jump as high he's a this
is actually a bit tough maybe we
unmouthful
spit
[Music]
cubby spit
[Music]
[ __ ] kitchen
[ __ ] ass back here
[Music]
not on my god damn watch
you know who i am
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
god
[Music]
okay
ride the spewing water up
i did
very nice pachinko
[Music]
what
[Music]
how dare you i didn't even see that it
was there i should have known that i did
see it from the other side it's like i
forgot that's my bad
ass
thank you
blessed ego welcome
[Music]
i don't know which one
does this make me a literal bomb
and then this one does what
oh i see okay
give it a try
yup love it it's like a boomerang
ruined your [ __ ] day not oh
it's a little bit scarier
he maybe hurt me a little bit
cub cub let's go cub you got it
oh i hit myself
i hit myself
[Music]
i have a
water bottle that's hitting his health
bar right now
i can't see past it no
cut i should have gotten the bomb
obviously i didn't know what i was
walking into
okay
what do the stars do
i would like one oh you have to hit a
fan i keep not hitting them
maybe not what do they do unclear
get out of here
oh i probably have to to to
no
damn it
unfortunate i'll take the cute hat
kirby in bad spot right now my friend
kirby
cubby got hurt there
kirby get the [ __ ] out
peace
stars off a base cubby to inhale yes it
does make sense
it's so funny how bad it looks when
they're far away um i would like this
meat
everybody just leave me to my meat
[Music]
you ever just blow up a dog
kirby is kind of an [ __ ] is the thing
[Music]
a lot of bombs my man
a lot of bombs
it's cool
though
you're on that man's day
you think you are get out of here
pumpkin
all right we doing good we doing good i
should go up here
what's all this
[Music]
excuse
[Music]
this little feet
oh my god
wow
oh my god
incredible
holy crap
[Music]
i just want to leave the sleeping once i
know that i shouldn't but
i actually have a picture of
queen bee my first foster dog with a
bubble
on her face
um
while she was asleep she had a little
bubble she was very cute
it did not get
bigger and smaller that's not gonna work
huh
that
is get out of here bunnies
not on my watch
[Music]
whoops
wrong button
i need the cone
it makes sense
nice why give me dummy
okay maybe
maybe drop ability
and then eat you
there we go
and then we're gonna
nice uh mouthful
rude
oh he looks so naked
[Music]
wow
holy crap
oh can i go in this no that's going to
be off the level
[Music]
i'm sorry kicking your butt if only you
were taking a nap
all right cub
back to regular cub i think
[Music]
goddamn did he just run off
okay okay king off you go
don't mind if i do
you trying to get spiked sorry birds
[Music]
you're a large one my friend how am i
supposed to get all the way up there
a cute like uh boss fight it's uh
it's just like the the nightmare bits in
the batman arkham games
i'm gonna water this bit come on jump on
it jump on it like the big nerd you are
all right let me do it
this is really well designed not only is
it extremely cute it's also very well
designed
this is nintendo's handsome naughty dog
strongly agree sean yes
take that naughty dog what are you gonna
do now
three of them
my tiny friends hello it's conby
it me
[Music]
i missed a tulip
damn
it's fine
if i let
one of the sort of dogs sleep in order
to do that
i'm cool with it
[Music]
you looking kind of tired are you okay
what kind of comment is that
do i look tired i don't feel tired i'm
fine yes thank you sorry i look tired
[Music]
oh my gosh
kirby was pulled into a mysterious
vortex that appeared in the sky over his
home planet on pop star
sorry home on planet pops up when he
woke up he was in a new world traveling
through that vortex also gave kirby a
new mysterious power let's see what it
can do onward to adventure
he really is coming out of his mouth
use your pointy head to jab below you
and bust open cracks in the ground all
in pipes you're out of control
control oh my god
a mystical new friend you met in him a
serious new world you found el elphillin
as he was trying to save the waldies
from the beast pack he seems happy to be
kirby's guide sharing helpful advice to
stay the one of these and rebuild that
town thanks elf belin
[Music]
what a great time
[Laughter]
you can't do that to me stop doing that
you got to stop doing that god
everybody keep sexualizing my son
correct though olo kirby really shown
why he's the main character in smash
bros i am a kirby mane
i am proud of my son
again i have this statue downstairs um
of kirby sitting on a star and it lights
up it's so cool and i spent a pretty
long time rigging that hole like i have
just like a bookcase i'll probably put a
picture up on it i'm actually just
waiting for the statue that i have at
the fun house office right now
to go grab that to add it to the
collection before i like show the photo
so i did do a video where i showed off
that collection but i want to do a
before and after photo of me rigging all
the lights
and put them to a smart switch so that
it automatically turns on at 5 p.m so
every single day all of my statues light
up it's sick
it took a few hours
it took a few hours but it looks
awesome
alright
let's go
to
[Music]
through the tunnel
i'm ready
sign me and coach let's do it
what a what the vibes are just so good
man
okay young man
you ready to jam out here
oh that's on fire
beat the slap the absolute crap out of
you sir i wonder if i have any like
water abilities i don't think i do
are you ready young cub
let's go
not today you did get me a bit that's
that's you made yourself look like a bit
less of a chad there kirby that's
that's disappointing
[Music]
get whatever this weird thing is
boom
who are you
[Music]
it's like
this song's like getting all metal
there's jamming in here
okay
[Music]
let's let's get him let's get him
i
did what what did i just do
what what
[Music]
i don't know what i did but it looked i
looked cubby look i keep pressing the
wrong button
oh thank god he can jump so much higher
than he can in smash
boom
all right
[Music]
kick your ass
it's the fly sweatiness of the atom oh
damn it i keep again pressing the wrong
button
thank god he can fly so far
um okay hang on
oh
it almost got spicy actually the aspect
of this level is i think also just
confusing my brain a little bit kick
those feet
kick those feet
back to
oh
there's a lot going on in here some kind
of roughness
you just ran right past me you idiot
you even trying
i gotcha
hidden waddles and gotcha
not you not you anyone but you what if
these oxygen tanks that's an interesting
choice whichever artist chose to put
oxygen tanks in the kirby game
hmm
curious
[Music]
[Music]
and some kind of like
used to be factory type thing here i'm
thinking
ew
it is like that trying to say something
whoa look at the spike with googly eyes
okay
cool guy okay
nothing
should i attack it or should i just run
i don't know if i can attack it as my
is my conundrum
don't think so
who do you think you are
get out youtube
not having it
[Music]
i wasn't even looking at it
[Music]
that makes sense that makes sense
kirby go fly
[Music]
hi
it's just so cute
i just i really feel like the world is
better for having kirby in it that's
that's my stance
[Music]
and i do hope that this game gets a
little bit harder right now i feel like
i'm a very big fan of the pacing
um i'm liking the enemy variety
but especially after metroid we know
nintendo can do it they've been doing it
kirby can do it too
[Music]
sounds like a dog what is that
[Music]
somebody here is making noise
i'm just not sure who
[Music]
maybe it's through here i don't know i
don't know
are right lighting the lamp supply
probably does do something they do have
sparks on them so i had thought that
they would light up somehow but
um oh i guess i can eat these guys
connie
[Music]
i keep forgetting to eat things even
though i am kirby
oh my god
just because i like oh i can't go out um
i like the sword so much
i always have
[Music]
that one clearly needed to be lit
[Music]
i could do that too punk mine's way
cooler than yours i'm a charizard
[Music]
why did he even come back
[Music]
i just ran off the edge but because my
water bottle's there it looked like a
corner
[Music]
i couldn't tell that it was an edge
amazing
get out of my face you too
out of it out of it
not having it get out see i do really
like the sword i just prefer the impact
of this sword
[Music]
a whole staircase kirby
[Music]
cubby that's much too big for your mouth
cubby there's just no way
how could anybody ever swallow something
that large
[Music]
i didn't i didn't even do that one on
purpose
[Music]
it just it just happened it just you
can't help it
kirby this is too big
as your mother i'm putting my foot down
i don't think we should do this one
it's too large
no the mother thing made it worse
there's a whole category for that
oh my god
look at his little arms
oh my god
what does tip over do
oh my god
it's like he's a whole tetris oh my
[ __ ] god
oh
i wish i had something else to say
i don't
it's just ore and wonder hey hey
i don't want to spit them out
i don't want to do it yet
okay it's fine we can we can spit it out
and we can get back in
[Music]
it's kind of gross though dude
climbing all over the thing that you
just
ate
it's a little bit nasty
and you're just gonna eat it again now
you got a little little paws on it your
little [ __ ] hooves have been all over
it now you're just gonna
you're gonna do it again
wait wait that's fire
[Music]
no i can keep that
keep it keep it oh damn it i messed that
up
oh well
[Music]
get slapped
who did this
who put the no kirby sign here
[Music]
who do you think you are
[Music]
how
dare you
i'm kirby and i will go where i want to
you would go too if it happened to you
[Music]
the kids these days know that song
or is that
you know as a millennial not a boomer
is that song two boomer
i don't know that kids know the cry if i
want to song you know what i'm saying
[Music]
hey of my face um okay i didn't actually
really assess what i was trying to do
here
gotta explode those maybe
is what i'm thinking
it's making that noise again
[Music]
it's too high for me i gotta go up here
maybe
i'm unclear
oh do i maybe get in it
i'm so slow okay let's give this a try
[Music]
run cubby
faster
i'm never gonna make that i'm too slow
[Music]
there's just no way
is there a way for me to move faster
that i'm just not aware of them
because i haven't really touched any
controls other than a and b
yeah there are different games where you
get inside of them
know didn't mean to do that i don't know
if i can run
x
it's fine we can keep moving i'll do it
later but that is definitely a thing i'm
supposed to do
i'm never trying to go for everything on
my first playthrough but i've definitely
missed two
[Music]
locked up cage friends
kirby
maybe not that good at this job
oh my god you're right move the stairs
that is that simple um i can't do it now
though
yeah i would have just had to move
stairs and i could just walk up there
but i can't go back through they don't
know
it's fine
you can just sleep down my friend
[Music]
why did i try to roast them they were in
a cage that was pretty messed up
actually it was an accident i didn't
mean to i wasn't thinking about it i
tried to light them on fire
oops
not great completion on that one
but we smashed it smashed it
we got through it
[Music]
his little feet
oh my god it's so cute
oh my god
[Music]
we just we just don't deserve
we don't deserve a curb
dumb mouth kirby
kirby gained the mysterious mouthful
mode ability after he flew through that
vortex
now he can stuff an entire dome into his
mouth wrap around one of these then
twist until it pops open think there's
anything good inside only one way to
find out
[Music]
bandana waddle dee was pulled through
the vortex along with kirby
[Music]
i'm a big fan of
cubby's androgynous vibes with this
flame helmet
hi
very cute
rocky rolling road okay let's go
i'll do that level again later when i'm
not on stream it's fine we'll figure it
out oh
oh
okay
i'm gonna keep going mainline for now
but we will come back for that we will
come back for that that sounds awesome
[Music]
boom i really want my sword back
[Music]
they have to make things less cute okay
goku
[Music]
i don't want to kill any of these things
see that's what the last of us got right
you you want to make a post-apocalyptic
game you talk to naughty dog make the
things terrifying
all right
[Music]
who you [ __ ] think you are you sneaky
son of a [ __ ]
doing sneaky sneaks no i don't have my
sword
it makes me a lot slower
don't make me swallow you tiny
dog with hat it is a dog
what the [ __ ]
do you think i can swallow
ah
you think i can swallow
no no that's not what i meant to do
i want i want oh okay you
he's got a gun
kirby's got a gun
[Music]
oh my god i look like a little
prospector
[Music]
you can't just be out here giving
kirby weapons like this
well the sword counts but
firearms now
this game's american propaganda
i knew it
you ever shoot a hedgehog in the face
sure i do
[Applause]
oh my god
[Music]
i can't make that i can't make that i
need the stairs back
[Music]
it's a shootout it's a right shootout
nice
[Music]
their crying noise is bad
not as bad as um
yoshi in that one game but
all right i see yes a lot of rocks got
it understood
do not squish cub cub has gun now
don't even test me
[Music]
i will shoot you in the face
[Music]
[Applause]
move your little feet
oh my god
i hope that this never wears off and
then i find this is as
absurdly pleasant the entire game
[Music]
no there's nothing up there
it's not it wasn't worth the risk
[Music]
she can fly for a long time
no
no no you don't get out of it
[Music]
i keep i keep blowing the air out um
[Music]
okay
[Music]
how to reach that
i don't think i can jump any higher than
that and that's not high enough to hit
it
hold b
oh oh i can aim oh i didn't know that
thank you chad appreciate that
[Music]
do i have a license for this weapon
that's what i would like to know also i
thought that the other way was forward
and now i'm worried that i've gone in
the wrong direction and i've missed
things
kirby confirmed bad at his job
okay
great let's do it
well i could probably just hit all three
of you at once right
[Music]
thanks for the donut
oh my god
amazing look at this go you little sharp
shoe to you
who is locking their prisoners behind
shooting games
what are you the joker
[Music]
that's a mess
you're right post-apocalyptic ain't no
licenses it's a great point
they got any room for that in the
post-apocalypse
absolutely destroyed that cute small dog
nice flip kerb all right i would really
like my sword back
[Music]
milk
oh my god
okay it's a crash bandicoot huh
[Music]
kick your ass
don't even try me
kick your ass
pick your ass too they'll get splatted
by the rock though weren't they oh
that's harsh
that is harsh
[Music]
hi
[Music]
i just want my sword back
absolutely dead
could not be more dead oh my god it's
time for carby
[Music]
we're doing it
copy go for
get out of my face
oh my god i feel like i'm on a rampage
this game feels violent for some reason
i just the destruction i've caused when
coming to these
people's homes you know i just
what about ethics
what about ethics
nobody's asking about ethics
at the beginning i have to jump turbo
doesn't jump
turbo and jump with two different kavi
waves
[Applause]
otherwise copy smash it's like i'm the
hulk
[Music]
[Applause]
just destroying everything
what is this demon souls
[Music]
come on bud there you go
[Music]
yeah
we did it
[Music]
we only missed one
guppy is a strict follower of
utilitarianism
[Music]
yeah but he's so cute though
hold down the button and aim to throw
didn't realize that
i guess it's probably been too long
since i played a kirby that i keep not
really i'm just pressing a and b and not
exploring any other option
got it hold aim throw throw hit boom you
can run around and throw them too or
roll them ahead of you to get an
explosive strike
[Music]
this is just the purest
thing that i've
ever played
it's
honestly incredible